[Música]
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump habló desde Mara lago tras
presentarse de Nueva York ante el Jurado
y declararse no culpable de los 34
cargos que le imputa la fiscalía por
falsificación de registros mercantiles
en primer grado Trump Se declaró víctima
de una injerencia electoral y arremetió
contra el fiscal del distrito de Nueva
York
el congreso peruano rechazó llevar a
debate la moción de destitución de la
presidenta Dina boluarte que había sido
presentada por la izquierda esto al
tiempo que el destituido mandatario
Pedro Castillo llamó a Naciones Unidas
para pedir justicia y aseguró que su
país vive una grave inseguridad jurídica
el 4 de abril es el Día Mundial de
sensibilización contra Las Minas
antipersonal entre 1999 y 2020 más de
143.000 personas han muerto resultado de
heridas por este artefacto para este año
el lema es la acción contra Las Minas no
puede esperar veremos Cuál es la
situación en Colombia
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Estados Unidos porque el expresidente
Donald Trump habló ante su simpatizantes
desde Mara lago en la Florida esto tras
declararse No culpable de los 34 cargos
penales que le fueron imputados en una
corte de Manhattan en Nueva York Trump
dijo que nunca pensó que algo ha sido
ocurriría en el país y arremetió contra
el fiscal del distrito de Nueva York
Alvin brack todos los delitos por los
que fue señalado el ex mandatario tienen
relación con la falsificación de
registros mercantiles en primer grado
todo esto relacionado con los pagos
ilegales a la actriz pornográfica stormy
Daniels en 2016 esto Dijo Trump desde
pum Beach
con este fiscal fracasado local acusando
a un expresidente de los Estados Unidos
por primera vez en la historia
basado en que cada
análisis dijo Es que no hay caso no hay
caso sigue diciéndolo pero no hay caso
El Criminal es el fiscal del distrito
porque
filtró un montón de información
privilegiada del Gran Jurado
[Aplausos]
Por lo cual Debería ser fiscalizada al
menos debería renunciar el caso de los
sobornos a la actriz
pornográficaniels ha sido el que hasta
el momento ha comprometido más al
expresidente Trump a pesar de que los
hechos ocurrieron en 2006 los sucesos
explotaron 10 años después durante la
campaña presidencial del líder
republicano desde entonces el expediente
ha tenido vaivenes con la condena del ex
abogado de Trump Michael cohen personaje
imprescindible para la fiscalía de Nueva
York que reabrió el caso después de la
Asunción del fiscal Alvin
ni los expedientes de mar lago ni la
toma del Capitolio el caso que más ha
comprometido a Donald Trump ha sido el
que involucra a la actriz porno stormy
Daniels y unos supuestos sobornos
pagados en 2016
el origen del problema se remonta a 2006
cuando la actriz y El Magnate
mantuvieron una relación sexual según
asegurado Daniels una versión desmentida
por Trump ella intentó vender la
historia de los medios de comunicación
primero en 2011 y luego en 2016 cuando
se convirtió en una amenaza para las
aspiraciones presidenciales del
republicano para silenciarla el Entonces
es abogado de Trump Michael cohen le
habría pagado 130 mil dólares Aunque
Trump afirmó que ese dinero era personal
y no de la campaña la justicia lo tomó
como un delito tras considerarlo un
gasto de campaña dado que podría haber
afectado su imagen como candidato sabía
usted sobre el pago de 130 mil dólares
astor mi Daniels no
Entonces por qué lo hizo Michael cohen
tienes que preguntarle a Michael cohen
Michael es mi abogado y tendrás que
preguntarle a Michael
cohen fue condenado en 2019 a 3 años de
prisión después de tildar de Injusto el
castigo y asegurar que sólo cumplió
órdenes de su jefe
Friends Espero que cuando me reúna con
mi familia y mis amigos este país esté
libre de xenofobia injusticia y las
mentiras que dominan nuestro país
todavía hay mucho por decir espero con
ansias el día que pueda compartir la
verdad
el fiscal de Manhattan Alvin asumió el
cargo del primero de enero de 2022 y
reabrió el caso que había sido cerrado
por su predecesor cohen excarceló en
2020 por la pandemia desempeñó un papel
trascendental para el avance de la causa
al testificar ante el gran Jurado
comienzo 2023 contrario a las
especulaciones la imagen de Trump no se
ha visto afectada severamente incluso
sus fondos de campaña han sumado 4
millones de dólares tan solo en las 24
horas siguientes a que se diera a
conocer su imputación
la agitación política continúa en Perú
El Congreso de ese país rechazó una
moción para iniciar un proceso de
destitución contra la presidenta Dina
boluarte la acusan de cargos
relacionados con la muerte de
manifestantes en las protestas
antigubernamentales la moción fue
archivada del mismo día en que el
expresidente Pedro Castillo detenido
desde el 7 de diciembre de 2022 pidiera
la intervención de la ONU para conseguir
justicia a propósito del ex jefe de
estado fue sancionado el martes con 15
días de comunicación limitada por haber
publicado una carta firmada en su cuenta
de Twitter desde la cárcel donde cumple
prisión preventiva del pleno del
Congreso de la república
El Congreso de Perú rechazó debatir una
moción de destitución contra la
presidenta Dina boluarte que fue
presentada por legisladores de izquierda
que la vinculan con decenas de muertes
en las protestas en su contra he votado
por la vacancia porque de los más de 60
muertos 49 han fallecido por proyectiles
armas de fuego que vienen de
instituciones del estado la propuesta
recibió 37 votos a favor 64 en contra y
diez abstenciones y ahora será archivada
en consecuencia no ha sido admitida la
moción de orden del día del pedido de
vacancia para la presidencia de la
república Y pasa al archivo las
manifestaciones que paralizaron el país
por varios meses comenzaron en diciembre
tras la destitución y detención del
presidente Pedro Castillo quien intentó
disolver el congreso y gobernar a través
de decreto Castillo pidió hoy la
intervención de Naciones Unidas para
encontrar justicia en su caso Porque
creo importante
decirle a esta sala que soy un preso
político porque el fondo de este
episodio tiene un interés político
concluyó
haciendo un llamado
y pidiendo la intervención de los
organismos de derechos humanos de la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas Ya
que en el Perú ni mi pueblo ni yo
yo encontramos justicia castillo y
boluarte también son investigados por la
fiscalía por la presunta financiación
ilegal del partido Perú libre en las
elecciones generales de 2021 la antigua
fórmula presidencial ahora dividida
niega las acusaciones y cree que los
expedientes en su contra son una
persecución política
el 4 de abril es el Día Mundial de
sensibilización contra Las Minas
antipersonal se calcula que entre 1999 y
2020 más de 143.000 personas han muerto
o resultado de heridas por este
artefacto para 2023 el lema es la acción
contra Las Minas no puede esperar a
continuación lluís Muñoz hace un repaso
de la situación en Colombia
así es un proceso de desminado
humanitario en Colombia uno de los
países que más víctimas ha registrado en
el mundo por Minas antipersonal este 4
de abril es el Día Internacional de
sensibilización contra su uso y Colombia
registró en el primer trimestre del año
un descenso de víctimas respecto al
mismo periodo de 2022 Aunque contó el
doble de muertes para el comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja las
consecuencias van mucho más allá de los
datos en estos lugares las comunidades
sobre todo la población civil se ve
afectada porque no puede seguir
utilizando sus medios normales todos sus
bienes están afectados por la presencia
estos artefactos exclusivos se generan
consecuencias como limitación para poder
acceder a sus cultivos poderse movilizar
libremente en sus territorios Acceder al
agua casa pesca y esto genera
dificultades también para acceder a los
bienes y servicios desde 1990 Colombia
ha registrado más de 2.000 muertos por
Minas antipersonal el país llegó a tener
715 municipios contaminados más de la
mitad del total de 1.122 tras el acuerdo
de paz con las Farc de 2016 el estado Ha
logrado tener cerca de 900 municipios
libres de minas una mejora que no bastó
para estar libre de Minas en 2021 fecha
a la que se había comprometido Colombia
actualmente tiene una prórroga hasta
fines de 2025 pero el objetivo se sigue
viendo difícil los grupos criminales que
quedan en el territorio colombiano
siguen utilizando Las Minas antipersonal
finalizamos con la conmemoración del
primer siglo de la compañía de
entretenimiento Warner Bros tras Cien
años de producciones es considerada una
de las empresas más estables del sector
es responsable de clásicos de la talla
del Mago de Oz El exorcista o Matrix
también de la mundialmente aclamada saga
de Harry Potter a lo largo de su
historia también lanzó emblemáticos
personajes como Bugs Bunny y los demás
Looney Jones e incluso la célebre serie
Friends con estas imágenes Nos
despedimos a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía
es la que me dijo que
[Música]